Speaker 1: Let's hear from a few more people via
the discord which you can find at David Pakman
dot com slash discord. We are going to go next to
Jeremy from Suffolk in the U.K.. Jeremy, welcome.
Speaker 3: It gives.
Speaker 1: Me. Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Hey. Sorry, I just joined.
You kind of caught me off guard.
I don't necessarily think I have a, like, a
question, per se. I guess I just. I know the
election's happening right now, and it's
going much better than what we thought,
but I still just have such frustrations with the
younger generation. And mine. My tired stems from
a military. I'm stationed here in the UK and
I'm going to unify to our people. In my section,
I supervise 40 plus people and like I
asked around seeing category interest
and who's going to register who's been on on
the ballot. Like none of those. None of them.
And it's zero interest and getting out to vote
and make their voices heard. And most frustrating
one was I have a transfer issue on my flights.
And when I asked her if she was going to vote,
she kind of gave me like a shoulder shrug. You
know, I think how things are for all people.
It is super frustrating. Just kind
of deal with that kind of mentality.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Which of course,
is a self-fulfilling prophecy,
right? If young people say, I'm not going to get
involved because politics is for older people,
they're basically seeing that politics is
for the older people who choose to vote.
It's a self-fulfilling, endless loop.
Speaker 3: That's the one thing I want
to say to her was, you know, there are
two political sides in our country right
now. And one of those sides would attack
or not even attack you. But like really,
I guess yet attack you in the way you choose to
live your life. And by you not voting, they're
kind of just like allows that to continue on. Yep.
Speaker 1: Without a doubt. Without a doubt right
now is the politics aside from being apathetic?
Is it also a right wing group of people?
Speaker 3: You know. So I really I try to
avoid that conversation mostly because there are
people who are more commensurate with my rank than
I came into conversation with. And I will tell
you, most of them are more right leaning. I do
think the the younger crowd is left leaning, but
at the same time, I try not to have that that for
discussion because it is not really my place to
to kind of influence how they how they view their
politics. I can make I can convince to try and go
out and vote. But me kind of expressing my ideas,
that's like using my rank, my position
to influence them. And that's like I know
that it's not generally okay in the military.
Speaker 1: Understood. Understood. Well, Jeremy,
I appreciate the call. Thank you.
Speaker 3: All right. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. There's Jeremy
calling in from the UK. Quite a situation
he's facing there. Let's go to Chris from
Atlanta. Chris, welcome to the program.
Chris from Atlanta, welcome. You're on.
And last chance for Chris from Atlanta.
Speaker 3: All right.
Speaker 1: Let's go to Aaron from Los Angeles.
Aaron from Los Angeles, welcome to the show.
Speaker 4: Hi, David. I was wondering if
you have been keeping up with what's been
happening with L.A. City politics at a local
level. There's been quite a lot that's been
going on in the past month.
Speaker 1: I really have not.
Speaker 4: So I guess the first
thing that happened was, ah,
the city council president had to resign
following a leaked audio of a racism scandal.
Speaker 1: Oh, yes, I did see that. Yes, yes, yes.
Speaker 4: So there was that that occurred. And
now it looks like in light of the elections, Rick
Perry still might win over Karen Bass. And I'm not
sure if you know who Recurso is.
Speaker 1: I don't I just
have not been following that race.
Speaker 4: I. Yeah. So he was actually
registered as a Republican for years before
switching over to Democrat, I think around 2020.
And Karen Bass is the more progressive candidate.
But in light of everything that's happening with
the homeless news and everything else, it looks
like a lot of people are going with a more,
I guess, center right candidate that's posing
as a Democrat. Mm hmm. So. Yeah, sorry. I guess
it's my apologies. It was just my question was
just, like, very neat and based around that.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, I am I apologize
that I'm not as familiar with that races as
maybe you are, but I appreciate you engaging with
it. And it's really important that we all engage
with our local races. You know, it's like it's
very interesting and relevant to follow. Like,
does Doug Mastriano become governor of
Pennsylvania? Fortunately, he doesn't.
But for most of us, the things that are affect
us day to day are local issues. Who's the
mayor? Who are the city councilors? What sort of
decisions are being made in our schools, etc.? So
good for you, Aaron, for following it all.
Speaker 4: Oh. Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. There
is Aaron from Los Angeles.